deuda más grande en el mundo para un
negocio que rinde frutos Ecuador canjeó
parte de su deuda por naturaleza por
medio de una operación financiera que le
permitirá reducir sus obligaciones y
ahorrar millones de dólares que ahora
dedicará la conservación Ha logrado el
canje de deuda por conservación más
grande de la historia de la humanidad
generando un ahorro de mil cien millones
de dólares al servicio de la deuda con
ello
450 millones de dólares se invertirán en
la protección de uno de los ecosistemas
más increíbles del planeta las Islas
Galápagos el movimiento respaldado por
el banco interamericano de desarrollo y
Estados Unidos combina diferentes e
innovadores instrumentos de mejora
crediticia y se convierte en un ejemplo
de soluciones a desafíos globales en
materia ambiental esto significa que se
ha canjeado deuda actual por un valor
aproximado de 16
30 millones de dólares por una nueva
deuda de 656 millones de dólares en
términos sencillos esto sería como
comprar un dólar por 40 centavos
los canjes de deuda por naturaleza
fueron populares en los años 80 durante
la crisis de deuda de América Latina
cuando los países dejaban de destinar
dinero a la protección ambiental
hoy resurgen como una oportunidad tras
una nueva crisis provocada por la
pandemia la mayor conversión de deuda
por naturaleza del mundo permitirá a
Ecuador proteger a perpetuidad esta
reserva compuesta por 13 Islas que son
el hogar de 3.500 especies el 25% de
ellas catalogadas como especies
endémicas